normally saying something's
two-dimensional would be a bad thing
but uh i feel like i'd be complimenting
it here
that was lame and obvious and i'm moving
on regardless
hey everybody take two doctor who
reviews
roll on and now it's time for
flatline i was curious to revisit this
one because
it's an episode that i like i liked at
the time and
i i've never disliked it but it's also
one that i would see
pop up like on episodes of people that
some people
really like or they think it's really
underrated i don't know anyone who
doesn't like it
but it seems like some folks i really
marked it as one of the true legitimate
highlights of capaldi's era
and i never felt that way about it and
having rewatched it
i still don't it is good don't get me
wrong
it's quite good in fact and there's a
lot to praise about it and that's
mostly what i'm going to be doing but
even the things that are good nothing
and it really blew me away
in the case of this particular episode i
do have to wonder if it's a little bit
like is a weird comparison a little bit
like the movie
it or i guess it chapter one because
nobody liked chapter two
but lots of people really liked it
chapter one
largely because they found it scary and
because i didn't i didn't like it nearly
as much
i wonder if part of it is p if other
people were a lot more
unnerved by the boneless as
a as a threat as a creature than i was
maybe that that would explain it but
that's me um
sort of postulating on it anyways
let's actually talk about the episode
i really do like the wonkiness going on
with the tardis
that uh its dimensionality is being
messed with and it ends up being smaller
and smaller
and i love the way that that gets teased
by having the door to get out be smaller
even though the rest of the interior has
not changed like that's
that's great and while some of the jokes
that it gets played for
are a little like it it's a neat idea
well executed um and i certainly think
it's an intriguing start to everything
definitely more so than the cold open
was which was
pretty generic like oh person
seems to be in danger oh they're dead
yeah the reveal of like kind
of what happened to him ish was a little
unique but
[Music]
the the setup wasn't i liked the uh the
use of the murals
and that no one knows who's painted them
and everyone thinks that they're
memorials to all the missing people
when in fact it's the boneless hiding in
plain sight that was
that was a nice move that was a good one
in general
the the shifting around like on the
walls and the floor
and that sort of two-dimensional and
when things
turn 2d like i'm thinking especially
like when the couch started
that i think that's pretty effective and
it's
nicely unnerving because it's the kind
of thing like you can
kind of comprehend what you're looking
at but it also doesn't really make sense
which is great what that does mean
unfortunately is
when the boneless take shape
and sort of are moving around
three-dimensionally
later on for me they're not as effective
now it's still a pretty neat effect and
so in terms of like what's going on with
the bodies and the visual effect overlay
that that they're doing
it works don't get me wrong but
at that point they're just a shambling
monster
like they move like zombies and now
they're just in three dimensions before
when they were two-dimensional
you felt like you didn't know where they
were gonna come from or how and now it's
just well
do we see them shambling down the tunnel
yet no well then they're not coming yet
whereas before
it felt much more like they could have
come from anywhere so
i i get the escalation and especially
with
the apparent goal of them trying to
become three-dimensional that it was
eventually going to get there i think
maybe they should have held off
them taking three-dimensional form until
the last possible minute
that might have worked a little bit
better for me the performances are
pretty good on this
and this one clara you know let's take a
pen and claw we'll come back to her
uh the supporting cast is good there's
uh there's rixie
um who's just nice and endearing and
there's also i
he had a name but in my mind he's just
the toll
which is a pretty good performance they
do a couple of interesting things with
him one i like the idea that the
uh saw the psychic paper doesn't work on
him because he has no imagination
the doctor's line is it takes a an
incredible lack of imagination
uh to to have that not work and i kind
of like that because we've seen psychic
paper
be defeated by before by people who are
trained to watch for it
but now it's just being defeated because
the guy doesn't have enough
imagination for it to work with and
conjure up something for him to see and
that's
kind of a cute idea i rather like that
um i mentioned you know the tartar
shrinking i i do like some of the
some of the practical upshots from that
like the doctor passing the
sledgehammer through to clara so and
she's taking it out of her purse it
becomes like the mary poppins person
where she takes the lamp out she just
pulls out this sledgehammer
i rather like that the bit where where
it becomes like thing from the adam's
family sticks his hand out
to get the tardis off the railway track
that was good
uh they there's a lot of clever things
done with that whole conceit
of what happened to the tardis i do like
that for
as grouchy as this particular doctor has
been especially up to this point that he
doesn't
leap to the immediate conclusion of this
is
an invasion these are enemies he
indulges for as long as he can get away
with the
idea that they don't know they're
hurting
or killing the people in our world
and i i like i think he held on to that
idea for
just the right amount of time he needed
the doubt
to be gone but he didn't hold on to it
to the point of
idiocy because it's the kind of thing
where if a character holds on to a
children it's like
dude just wake up at what to what's
going on you're in denial he never
was at that point and then i also feel
like
the the degree to which he tried
to give them a way to
not be monstrous really
feeds into that thing towards the end
and i i love it when
he's in the tardis getting ready to come
out you know the power's back on
you know you're monsters that is the
role you have decided
decided to play and he gets this growl
in his voice so it seems that i
must play mine
the man that stops the monsters oh
that's good that moment's
really really good so and it felt
properly built up too
that was really nice oh there was one
other effect
thing i wanted to mention with the with
the boneless that
started out as a great effect but then
boy did they botch it
so there's this shot
that has riggsy clara
cole and fodder number three
um who you know they're all standing
around
and i had not caught this before
i don't know if i had just forgotten or
like hadn't noticed but
you can see the shadowy hand come down
and
start to reach but it's
placed really well because you've got
like characters here here and here and
it's
back here like right in the gap between
two characters
grabs fodder number three and yanks him
back and it's
great until the yank because what should
have happened is it should have grabbed
him
yanked him and the shot should have
stayed static and he was just
gone what they did instead was he
grabbed him
yanked him and the camera follows him so
it's just a locked-on shot of this one
guy going
for seven seconds i counted them out
it's
a really long time and it just it's just
zooming backwards and it fades to white
it it it's a shame because the
the effect and the use of the shot of
everything of the thing coming down and
reaching forward is really good but
thank god it wrecks it
once it grabs him ah it's terrible i
i mentioned uh the apple and
there's a couple things about him i like
that and doctor who's done this a couple
times they yeah the show did this
with voyage of the damned i like that
the
least likable character does survive and
the doctors a little annoyed
at that um but i do like that it
lends a more realistic sense of
the unfairness and the unjustness
of the universe where yes some people
were saved but
not who you not who the audience and
certainly not who the doctor will depict
um so i do like that that said
um oh wait i also like that that he like
turns out to be right about a few things
early on
but he has a moment where
he grabs the tardis out of
clara's purse so that i
so there can be struggle for it and gets
knocked down this
down this hole
why it's a super contrived moment and
here's the thing
i could have bought it if clara like
had the box in her hands and was you
know talking directly to it and he
and he grabbed her and like either give
me that or like this is
you know it could have felt more
spontaneous but he reaches
into her purse to get it
and it feels very under-motivated and
very contrived by the plot
to just get the tardis knocked down on
and on to the railroad tracks it's
it's a very ham-fisted moment it doesn't
really work so
okay let's talk about clara and this one
i have very mixed feelings about her
huge shock i know so
the first thing is um i like
that she initially tries to pass herself
off at the doctor as the doctor and kind
of
mockingly at first um you know as a way
to just make fun of him
but then is genuinely trying to think
what would the doctor do what would he
um
want of me you know what can i try
you know and sometimes asking him and
then sort of taking her own initiative
especially knowing what happens later
and the fact that
spoilers for down the line
but later on the fact that she tries to
be like the doctor
gets her killed it's
really nice to see these early warning
signs
um and not only that she's doing this
but that the doctor recognizes that this
is not a good
thing he's gotta he he's got a line when
he realizes that she lied to him
last episode about danny being fine with
her traveling
with him he says to her
lying is a vital survival skill
and a terrible habit
that's a great line also very true
from my experience and he's got another
one later on
that um he says because she
said i did good why won't you say i did
good and he said
you were an exceptional doctor clara but
goodness had nothing to do with it
which in some ways brings back the idea
that he's struggling with the idea
of whether or not he is a good man
and he sees her emulating him and he's
like
i'm not sure i'm watching a good
person do good um
so i i'm liking that i'm liking that
interaction and
and everything going on there and i also
like how clever
clara's plan was to get the tardis
recharged
that was really good
but then
then we get to her phone call with danny
and the lying continues she continues to
dig
that hole which i talked last time about
why
that makes me not like her now granted
it's resolved part of it because the
doctor is no longer unknowingly
complicit in the fact that she is lying
to danny
but she still is
and part of that
is at this point she's in a situation
where
for what he knows about the doctor they
don't address it
in this episode whether or not um
he suspects but like if we start the
next episode and he doesn't
suspect and it's not at all mentioned
that he thinks she's still seeing the
doctor
then they've made danny an idiot how
stupid you think i am
because even if he doesn't think that
immediately like he was on a phone call
where she was canceling plans and
huffing and panting and this sounded
like a broken window
and i i'm sorry no matter what excuse
she comes up with
he has to at least consider the
possibility that she's still seeing the
doctor given what he already knows about
the doctor and the kind of situations
that being with the doctor puts her in
how stupid you think i am if i see no
evidence that he ever does
then then at that point the writers are
just throwing danny under the bus
so i'd
really i had forgotten
about the fact that clara lies to danny
and i think part of the reason i'm
forgotten about it was because i knew
dairy
danny found out about the doctor
relatively early
so my memory had like somehow changed
that in my head to be like well he knew
he found out and then he knew the rest
of the time but it wasn't that and i'd
really forgotten
that she's kind of terrible to him
this is a this is a very serious
betrayal of his trust
that and it's an ongoing one it's not
something that she did once
and because she she even tries to
justify it you know
is it a bad thing to lie to protect
somebody
and that's a question that i've wrestled
with at points in my life
and i don't have an answer like so many
things it's a case-by-case basis but
what i can tell you is
if the answer is ever yes then it's yes
because of something that happened
once if it's an ongoing concern
then no you're not lying to them to
protect them you're lying to them so
that you can continue to do
what you want to do if you did something
once
that telling them would hurt them and
it will not happen again there's a
conversation to be had there but that's
not what she's doing
she's continually recommitting the
betrayal of his trust by going out with
the doctor
so i'm watching her rationalize this and
i'll say what i said last time
it's not that i don't buy that as a
characterization
it's valid it's human i
recognize it but i don't like watching
it
so that's sort of where i am
on flatline there's a lot more good than
bad in it i know it seems like i
nitpicked
i think it probably didn't help that i
ended on clara it might give you the
impression that i didn't like it all
that much i do
i think it's really good i think it's
well executed
on most of the things that it is
attempting to do
it just didn't bowl me over the way that
i think it did with some
folks and the result is i'm
happy to watch it again but it's not
like top of my re-watch list
um yeah so that's flatline
you re-watched it lately what'd you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something on down in the
comments let's talk about it i have a
patreon
naturally it is what is currently
keeping the lights on
around here so if you are able in any
amount to help me out there that would
be greatly appreciated there are perks
you get to vote in polls
for what topics may get covered in
future and you also get early access
to certain videos but even if you are
not able to lend that kind of support
liking subscribing sharing this around
all those do help the bell apparently
matters
more than i want to admit so add that to
the list of things that would help me
out but you know what if you don't want
to you don't have to
end of the day you're the council i'm
just running the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
hmm
[Applause]
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
oh